(explosions)
pupupupupupupupupupupupupupupups
près 20 ans la voix de la Russie
nsnsns le monde.
- Sergueï Lavrov est depuis
dans le monde.
Mais récemment,
l'indébonananable ministre russe
des Affaires étrangères semble
avoir endossé d'autres habits :
ceppppppppppppppppppppppppppppp,
les éléments de langagesusususun
sur la guerre en Ukraine.
Une transformation totale aux
yeux de Lawrence Cannon, ancs ss
étrangères, qui l'a bien connu.
LAWRENCE CANNON, ancien ministre
canadien des Affaires étrangères
- J'aime pas dire ieieieieieieis
le type avec lequel on était
en mesure de pouvoir dialoguer.
Je pense qu'il est, avec
le temps
- Diplomate de carrière,
iiiiï Lavrov était auparavant
apprécié de ses pairs.
Habile négociateur, il défendais
de la Russie, mais sesinterlocui
quelqu'un avec qui on pouvait
discuter...
... s'entendre et même rigoler.
d'd'd'd'd'hui, Sergueï Lavrov et
considéré comme un apparatchik
du régime de Moscou, un faucon
internationales...
... boycotté par les diplomates
la parole à l'ONU.
YANN HWANG, ambassadeur de
France à la Conférence de l'ONU
- Il était hors de question
qu'il déploie en ce moment
et de lui laisser un
comme si c'était normal,
dans un temps normal.
prendre au sérieux les théories
du complot darararararar le chef
de la diplomatie Russe.
Lorsqu'il prétend, par exemple,
que les États-Unis financent des
laboouououououour fabriquer des
armes biologiques en Ukraine...
orororororororsqu'il affirme que
les massacres de Marioupol
ou de Boutcha sont en fait
des mises en scène, que
les victimes sont des comédiens.
- Moi, je pense qu'il ne croitpl
dit. C'est un homme trop
intelligent pour pouvoir
croire... pour pouvoir
croire ces propos-là.
- La réalité, selon les
observateurs, c'est que même
s'il reste très fidèle à
Vladimir Poutine, Sergueï Lavrov
n'a aucune influence sur lui.
Son seul choix, selon cet
analyste, était de partir
ou de rester.
Et quitter le gouvernement de
Vladimir Poutine, c'est aussi
renoncer à beaucoup d'avantages.
♪ ♪ ♪
Selon une enquête du militant
anti-corruption Alexeï Navalny,
aujourd'hui emprisonné,avavavavp
de son poste doré.
Sa maîtresse et sa belle-fille,
sans emploi officiel,
possèderaient pourtantvovovovove
et appartements valant
des millions.
♪ ♪
Il est aussi questiondedededede
prestige et de voyage personnels
en jets privés appartenant à des
oligarques multimilliardaires.
Une situation compromettante
qui le rendrait vulnérable
et, donc, docile.
Le destin de Sergueï Lavrov
reste donc intimement lié
à celui de Vladimir Poutine,blbs
de partir. Et même si les ponts
avec le gouvernement russe
paraissent difficiles
à rétablir, lorsque cette crisïv
restera sans doute, pour
l'Occident, le moins mauvais
des interlocuteurs